be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly what's going on guys this is
Rob and one of the most common requests
that I get from you guys is the question
of what is Ragnarok what does this have
to do with Thor I don't understand can
you explain it make it make sense and so
that's what were going to be doing in
this video and so simply put Ragnarok is
the cycle of the destruction of Asgard
all beings within Asgard including Thor
and Odin as well as low key and then the
rebirth of Asgard and so in order to
make this make sense what I'm going to
do is I'm going to go ahead and give you
guys this sort of Chronicle with regards
to how it was Asgard came into existence
as well as the key action that had
changed the Ragnarok event and it
ultimately brought Ragnarok to an end
forever the origin of Asgard is given to
us in Thor annual issue number five in
1976 and what we're told here is that at
some point in the distant past or at
some point along the line there was
basically a void where everything
existed there was really nothing there
it was simply just this empty space now
when I say everything I mean absolutely
everything earth all the universes or I
guess the universe itself ask are the
whole nine yards it was simply just an
empty void now in this empty void
eventually came a landmass now this
landmass was split into two parts you
had the frozen barren wasteland in the
North that had 12 frozen rivers flowing
to the south and in the south you had
this firey barren wasteland that had 12
fiery rivers flowing to the north now
there came a point whereby these two I
guess these twelve rivers are these
twenty four rivers in total converged
into one another and it created this
very temperate climate but what
ultimately ended up happening is that as
time progressed the frozen rivers from
the north began to overtake the fiery
rivers from the south and so what ended
up happening in this sort of mesh of
this area here this sort of middle
ground is that a being came into
existence named a mere I think it's
pronounced humorous why am i R and this
was basically the first being to exist
in what would become Asgard as well as
the very first frost giant now what is
up happening here is that as we know
with frost giants when they're exposed
to warmer temperatures their bodies
begin to shrink in size and this is
exactly what happened with the mirror
what is up happening here is that warmer
air from the south begins to move toward
the north and when it does you're mayor
begins to shrink in size and so once
your mirror begins to shrink its
revealed to us that two beings come into
existence a man and a woman then these
are basically another version of the
frost giants keeping in mind here that
on Jotunheim is not just frost giants
you also have various other forms of
giants but they're not wildly discussion
important for this discussion the fact
remains here that in addition to this
creation of life after Bor after after
you Mir almost said Boram you after your
mirror what we also find is that a
bovine comes into existence now we're
not told how this bovine gets there
we're simply just told that it's there
and the role of this bovine is to
effectively provide all the Giants with
the nourishment they need by allowing
the Giants to nurse the nurse on the
bovine the bovine itself gets his own
sustenance by licking away at the
various forms of ice now one of these
blocks of ice said it looks away for a
period of time eventually takes on the
form of bori now bori bu RI is actually
the father of bor who in turn is the
father of odin and the result here is
that Asgard begins to take form as we
know Odin eventually married Frigga they
had Thor and then they adopted Loki from
from King lafi of the frost giants now
this is a very important important thing
and the reason why I say that is because
there was a prophecy that was foretold
in Asgard that Loki would bring ruin to
the end of everybody he would basically
destroy Asgard he would leave the
enemies of Asgard against Asgard and
this is the reason why every time Loki
did anything nefarious whether it was
some measure of trickery or whether it
was something serious everybody would
freak out because they thought that this
was going to be the the time when Loki
initiated a scar I'm sorry initiated
Ragnarok now what we're going to do is
we're going to go ahead and jump from
this origin story of Asgard into Thor
disassembled which was given to us
around 2004 2005 and what this story did
is it basically told us why Thor was not
part of Avengers disassembled and wifer
was not in civil war what we learn here
is that Loki in effect begins a campaign
to attack Asghar he actually has his own
version of Mjolnir made along with other
hammers that allow him to overtake
Asgard and so what ends up happening
here is that as Thor
trying to find a way to get back into
Asgard as well as defeat Loki he
basically goes on this quest to gain the
same kind of wisdom that Odin had and so
what he learns here is that the I guess
destruction of Asgard was currently
taking place and for disassembled is not
the first time this has happened that in
fact we don't know how many times this
has happened but apparently this has
happened for millennia it's happened for
years upon years a number so high that
we can't even count that as guard came
into existence that the continuity of
Asgard continued that eventually Loki
waged war against Asgard and Asgard was
destroyed the difference here is that
there had never been an instance in the
history of the cycle of Ragnarok where
Thor had been banished from the planet
Earth that had never taken
I'm sorry banished from from Asgard that
had never taken place before and so what
we learn is that the purpose of Odin
doing this a banishing Thor to the
planet Earth was to basically throw a
cog in the wheel of Ragnarok because
Odin had learned what had been going on
he learned that they had been dying and
then being reborn and then dying and
they were reborn over and over and over
again and so what happens here is Thor
learns that there are beings called the
ones who sit above in shadow and the
ones who sit above in shadow are
basically individuals who feed on this
cycle of the destruction of Asgard and
the rebirth of Asgard and so once the
word learns about this he actually
destroys the ones who sit above in
shadow and in response
everybody in Asgard dies and has guard
itself is totally destroyed and so while
everybody on the planet Earth assumes
that Thor is actually dead in fact he's
really in this kind of stasis he's kind
of in this in-between realm where he's
not really alive but he's not really
dead he's really just kind of waiting
but the fact remains here that this is
what Ragnarok is Ragnarok was the
endless cycle of the destruction of
Asgard the rebirth of Asgard and then
the cycle repeating itself over and over
and over again now with regards to the
character of Ragnarok again he's pretty
straightforward there came a point at
somewhere along the line in the Marvel
continuity when Ironman had first met
Thor but he had taken one of Thor
strands of hair and when he did his goal
was to basically clone Thor at some
point along the line we didn't know when
that point would be and we didn't really
know what the reason would be behind it
we just knew that Ironman was likely to
do this and this really came to fruition
in M civil war when Reed Richards Hank
Pym and Tony Stark realized that they
were going to need some version of Thor
that Thor was basically their powerhouse
he was the only character that could
really stand up and defeat all of the
other superheroes that were united
against against the pro registration
movement and so what ends up happening
here is when they create a cyborg
version of Thor when they create
Ragnarok that it actually ends up going
crazy it kills Bill Foster and they
considered it to be I guess
malfunctioning of some sort and so Reid
Richard actually takes it time to
reprogram it at which point it begins to
function the way it's supposed to but
that's basically what the Ragnarok
character is again he's pretty
straightforward and he's really not that
significant he's really just kind of an
interesting concept but analyst I hope
this video makes sense to you guys if
you did let me know if it didn't then
I'll do my best to explain a little bit
further down in the comment section but
uh yeah so I will catch you guys